non-minimalists
i was just wondering if you guys tend to
use the law of attraction to help
manifest minimalism and or
any sort of success or whatever it is
that you want in your life
and how that has been for you rob when i
hear cat's question why do i
i tense up when i hear two things i hear
law of attraction and all of a sudden
i and it's my own negative response it's
the woo-woo radar it's the woo-woo
there's something there but then also
the word manifest like it's another
woo-woo alarm bell for you
for whatever reason it is it's nails on
a chalkboard for me and it shouldn't be
and i should be more open-minded to
things like this
um because when i hear it i almost don't
even know what it means
notice is that a question
was there a question at the end of that
sentence
yeah what uh why do i have this allergy
there we go
allergic to woo wooiness uh my guess is
you
have a instinctual reflex
against something that seems to
take this vast mysterious
extraordinarily generative universe and
boil it down to
one law it actually feels to you
too minimalism too simplistic
so the impulse in the question is
wonderful how you think about things
profoundly shapes what they even are so
that's why her
her question is so powerful is she has
come into a way of understanding the
power of
how you choose to name the experience
because that shapes what the experience
even is
so an example would be uh recently i was
talking to this guy
who said to me and he was
he was lovely he was talking about his
own life and he now has a daughter and
he's married and he's
exploring how he's going to live he's
young
businessman and he said you know every
generation
wants to one-up the generation before it
was like okay first off totally
understand the impulse
but let me say that word back to you and
tell me how your body hears that word
one up he's like oh
tense it's like yeah one up is what he
said
uh competition i said fall that
competition meaning what he's like oh
win or lose oh and then you evaluate
yourself whether you want or lose so
that phrase sounds wonderful each
generation wants to one-up the one
before it but what it actually
the experience of it is a tense
experience of scarcity
so there's all of these energies hidden
in a statement like that that can just
fly right under the radar like oh yeah
every generation
um so the the power
of thinking about how you think about
the world is it alerts you
to all the ways that you're actually
framing your experience
in ways that aren't going to take you
anywhere you want to go
yeah the the language is so powerful you
can improve upon that you can even use
the word improve upon you could say
each generation wants to improve upon
the previous and all of a sudden you've
give more there you go hand less to
unlearn
yeah yeah wonderful impulses so
underneath the question let's go back to
why you threw up in your mouth at the
question
the truth is there are these
extraordinarily
subtle shifts
in how we view everything so one example
was you can view life through a lens of
scarcity and lack
or you can view life through a lens of
abundance
and generativity generosity and these
are
they exist almost so deep in the self
that you can't even see them
you know i mean they're so close in here
but they're actually what you look
through the gift of something like
law of attraction it simply alerts
people to if i am
operating from a place of scarcity and
lack then i'm going to see everything is
competition the goodness that comes to
others will always be a threat to me
which leads to jealousy and envy
and it ultimately shrinks heart and soul
if i see the earth and this world
believing in is abundant and can provide
for all
and i'm going to be fine that's going to
profoundly
shape things how's that yeah
look at you he's twitching less
well i do think about the language with
with my daughter in particular so
uh you our our the way we end every
episode is love people use things
because the opposite never works
and and the problem is we often say we
love
something like i love ryan but oh man i
love these chairs
right and same word for chairs and ryan
right and we have a language problem
really right and and uh new chairs could
be that awesome
and ella always argues with me she's
like but i love my robe and i'm like and
well it made me realize like oh
like this is what children do is they
love things and they get confused with
you know the things that they love and
and it's misplaced priorities and all
these other things it's because they're
children they don't have a fully
developed prefrontal cortex and and
but we as adults don't we do the same
thing
i still say i love this chair and i i
get attached to
to these things i give meaning to things
that don't deserve that meaning right
well it's interesting because you know
if i say i love you
versus i love that chair it's two
completely different emotions
right and and it's interesting how i
mean this goes back to the language
thing if you're looking at just the
language the law of attraction
sounds really silly but like when i
think of the law of attraction it's
it's very emotional for me like it's not
like
oh if i think i'm gonna make a million
dollars it's gonna drop on my lap it's
more like
uh what would i do with that why do i
want a million dollars what am i going
to do with that oh what i really want to
do is i want to be financially free i
want to be able to give to others
so then i start to focus on that which
leads to actions to do that
which really even in the movie what is
it called the secret
the law of attraction movie i mean every
single one of those people who they
interviewed
there was so much action that went
behind their law of attraction
but that like i feel that though when i
see hear the law of attraction it's like
i feel the action that comes along with
it
so yeah i uh yeah you and i kind of
disagree on that the love thing
um i agree with you and i try to use it
that way that we talk about
um but if someone says it like i don't
let it interrupt
their moment that they're experiencing